okay we'll
we'll get started um looks like nobody
else is joining us this is a bigger
crowd than i was expecting for such a
dull topic um but thank you all for
being here um so we're gonna be talking
about distributed tracing in dot net six
i realize dot net seven is out but um
dot net six was when i wrote it so
that's what we're doing um
we're using a product called or a
library called open telemetry um
so
i'm martin thwaites a developer advocate
at a company called honeycomb but i am
an observability evangelist first um
always was um and
you can catch me on twitter i normally
rant about this kind of stuff um
on there
so we're going to talk about a few
things i'm going to start by
explaining a bit about what
observability is i'm going to talk a
little bit about um what open telemetry
is and then we're going to go through a
little bit a little few bits about
how to implement that in net
spoiler it's really easy it's like 10
lines of code um so i'm going to try and
get you know at least 40 minutes out of
this um but it is very very simple we'll
talk about a few other concepts um
around things like the open temperature
collector and how that's useful um and
some of the more interesting and scary
concepts um around open telemetry um
so um
funny story we're trying to find out uh
find a picture that kind of embodies
what observability is because it's a
wide topic
and this was the best one that we could
come up with
the the idea of observability is how
well can you understand the internal
state of your system um by the outputs
that that system gives
um so the idea of a child
not knowing what's underneath the rock
until they look under the rock and then
they find more rocks and then they lift
up more rocks and then you put all the
rocks back down put the moss back on i
wasn't the last person to touch it
honest um but that's the the idea of
observability is this idea that you can
visualize what's happening inside of
your system by the outputs that it gives
you so not reaching inside your system
and grabbing things out but having your
system output information that you can
then do
it's where honeycomb was formed which is
the company i work for um
and it was all about this idea of how do
we make people
rely on their production observability
more than they rely on their debugging
how do we make debugging in production
as good as debugging locally
so um what is observability in general
so wikipedia defines it
like that
so um it's that internal state so asked
a couple more people for their ideas on
what exactly observability is so charity
majors are um co-founder who coined the
term about six-ish years ago um it's
about unknown unknowns and we talk a lot
about these ideas of what you know and
what you don't know and what you don't
know you don't know
and observability is for those unknown
unknowns the things that you don't know
um
so paul bruce who runs the olive fest
which is a
a conference like this specifically
around observability um is it's about
designing our systems to intentionally
emit information so that intentionality
of you writing your system so that they
intentionally emit information that you
can use to understand that but it's also
about the people who operate your
platform but also the people who rely on
your platform so the the people who are
maybe your ops team um who are then
running that um thing in production so
you're actually intentionally emitting
information out of it
now observability is all about asking
questions of your system after it's gone
live now we've all done
i would imagine a production system
where
something went wrong and you said it'd
be nice if we had this
um so you then do another release
with some more logging um inside of
there and then you were oh oh it doesn't
happen anymore so i've now missed that
opportunity
the idea of using observability is that
you don't know what you might need to
know so send all the information that
you can and then when something does
actually happen you've got that
information to be able to see so the
sorts of things that you might ask of
your system so um
is this feature being used uh might be
an interesting one that you want to see
so this isn't just about debugging this
isn't just about something went wrong
it's all about how can i observe my
system and know what's happening in that
system in production
um but it also goes down to that really
sort of core level performance stuff
like what about when things are in two
regions that's something you can't see
locally one's in u.s east and one's in
eu west ones in i don't know um somebody
come up with another region um and
when a request is transitioning now
maybe it's just one request maybe it's
five requests maybe it's 100 requests
but it might be very small the number of
requests and this is things you don't
know until you go into production you
don't know that you want to know
so that's the the idea um around
observability in general
um so then we go a little bit further
and we start to talk about tracing or
more specifically distributed tracing
tracing is this idea of profiling your
code
it's the idea of using things like
causality so the idea that one thing
happened and then that caused this thing
to happen that caused this thing to
happen that caused this thing to happen
which is very very different to using
logs
so if you are doing logging and doing
structured logging you are um a lot of
the time we get this well
traces are just fans are just like
structured logs aren't they
the idea of tracing is the idea of
causality that this http request that
came into service one then went through
these lines of code that did this those
three lines of code then went off to
call this search service over here and
then this service did this one this and
this and that went to a database and
that went to a redis cache and it's
about that causality now you can have
lots of log lines that tell you all
those things that causality is really
really important when you're talking
about high load systems
it's important to note as well that
distribute tracing is not a tool it's
not something that exists that you buy
it's not something that
you can just implement there are
libraries that do tracing but tracing
itself is a concept not a library
speaking of libraries what is open
telemetry so open telemetry is um the
number two project on the cncf
projects it's a language agnostic
protocol first
idea of how do we look at different
systems that are in different languages
and provide that distributed tracing
over all of these different things it's
built on top of the w3's tray standards
w3c trade standards um so it is based in
an actual standard but it's a an
initiative that came together from
two
competing initiatives called open census
and open tracing they came together and
went well how about we work together and
make one thing that everybody uses
it's now being adopted um
will it be number two in the uh the list
you can imagine that it is being adopted
um very very widely
um
and i
yeah i didn't remove that last term
on that slide um so yeah bullets roboto
regular um it does that as well um
so um what is the trace when we talk
about open telemetry so um
the trace is the thing being done so if
you think about http request your traces
from your outside of your request
and everything that happens within there
that conceptually is a trace it's the
thing that's been done you can format a
trace however you want you could say
that i only want traces on this system
over here or i only want traces on this
system here and i don't want any traces
for the thing above i generally don't
subscribe to that methodology but a
trace is conceptually the thing that's
being done
it consists of a few things
so we've got
things like child spans
which are little spans within there so a
trace in itself is just a span that
doesn't have a
root to it
you can see some bits of information on
the side there can't the kind of things
that it would um encompass it encumbers
something called baggage which we'll
come to which is the foot gun that you
never thought you wanted
and it also has things called tags or
attributes which are all the different
bits of information
around each of those spans that's being
created
so
open telemetry.net core or asp.net core
we're going to focus on asp.net core um
the stories around console logging and
various other bits is
not as fully fledged as it is in asp.net
core
um
asp.net core the implementation right
now is still in release candidate um i
think it's 9.3
i think we're adopting the microsoft
versioning methodology um so we'll be at
rc 9.3 pre-alpha 7.7 rtm soon i'm sure
um
it is being used in production by some
very very large companies so i wouldn't
let that put you off in using it
but it is marked as an rc at the moment
um whether when we get to um full um i
don't know um but there is a lot of talk
about that being very very soon
um so
the first thing we're going to have to
do is talk about
something called activity now
this is one of the most annoying things
around open telemetry right now
because open telemetry uses terminology
called spans and
traces and attributes and baggage and
various other bits
microsoft in their infinite wisdom said
no
we don't want that we didn't invent that
so we're going to use something called
activity which already existed
you know props to him for that they use
something that already existed it exists
in the bcl um so
you'll see a lot of mention when you're
looking at the tracing libraries um on
the the sdks that are in the different
languages that the terminology doesn't
match with asp.net and net
that is
an annoyance and a complication
once you get your head around it
it is really easy to understand
my recommendation is if you are writing
libraries if you are writing
open source libraries if you are writing
shared libraries to be used inside your
organization using the inner source
method
i would advise that you use activity
the reason is that that means that
you're not bringing in an external
dependency on open telemetry which
brings a hard dependency on an external
library
the idea of open telemetry gives you
things like propagation so the idea that
you can properly propagate a context
from one service to another it gives you
other things around this transition
those are really useful when you're
writing an application when you're
actually writing your first party
service that's going to call out to
other things
that's really useful
it's not as useful when you're writing a
library to abstract away your cosmos db
usage
it's not as useful in that context
now if you are writing those libraries
then try to think about things like
should i have is this span enabled one
of the other annoying things is when you
try and create a spam which we'll look
at in the moment you have to check
whether it's null because if it's not
observed then it's null um which means
that you get problems in your code if
somebody doesn't observe the thing that
you're trying to emit um which is really
annoying but
these are all things that have been
worked through um so
like i say microsoft decided to use
activity all the demos that we're going
to be talking about today are using
activity
um it is the
sort of um the concepts that's in the
open telemetry docs
so that's what we're going to be using
to go through they work the same you can
use your application in your application
you can use activity
you can use the open telemetry sdks and
bring those in as well it's entirely up
to you which one you want to do
so
how easy is it i said it's very very
easy about 10 lines of code um
three packages
you can actually do it without the three
packages if you really want
you don't need all of them
but what we're doing there is we're
bringing in the hosting package so the
way that open telemetry works
we will get some traces and some spans
those spans will go into it in memory
buffer internally and on a regular basis
it will flush those out to a third party
or first party if you're using something
like jager
so that's what our hosting package does
which is then going to be doing this
flushing periodically of the spans that
have been created
we've got a instrumentation for asp.net
core now everything that we're doing we
need to instrument we need to say this
is the thing that we want to monitor
the instrumentation libraries are these
are auto instrumentation libraries
they're written by microsoft the asp.net
one is
co-authored by microsoft which says that
these are the things within asp.net core
that i would like to emit you have some
options that you can turn on and off in
there but we're saying that we'd like to
know what the what the http request
route was
we'd like to know
what the user agent was on that request
they're creating these spans for us
bringing in these libraries allows us to
just go yes i'd like all those please
send them over to my tracing provider
it's fine
we've also got the the one for http so
that's the http client
allows you to do a lot of things around
the request handlers and things like
that around http client
these are all libraries that available
to you
um there are things like the sql client
so if you bring the sql client in that's
going to instrument things like the um
the command text that you send over the
parameters that you've sent in there all
things that you can then
report on in whatever tool you use
to receive these traces on the other end
but there's a lot of these that are also
instrumented
my caution would be
auto instrumentation will get you so far
it is step one
it is not step
end
implement these libraries
go home
these are the first steps they will give
you a level of visibility
um normally you'll get these things and
you'll go
wow
we call it um the mtt wtf
the mean time to what the was that
because these auto instrumentation
libraries are going to give you a level
of information that you didn't think you
needed
because they will tell you things like
it's one user
it's one user that's causing all of
these problems in my graphs on grafana
wow this is really important information
but that's step one
the next step is then going what's
interesting about my application
why is my application interesting i've
got an algorithm that i'm going to run
inside of my application
so i want to wrap that and i want that
to be a span i want the inputs into that
algorithm to be output for me to be able
to report to say that algorithm runs
slow on a tuesday when the data center
is 72 degrees because i've attached that
as an
attribute
um don't do that
but these are the things that you now
get to your next level of saying these
are what's interesting about my
application because every application is
different
so then how do we then set it up
i would imagine everybody here is using
the
at least.net core
possibly even minimal apis this is
minimal apis if you've not seen them
they are really really cool especially
if you're writing microservices
it is simple
it is add open telemetry tracing
tell it which one of the
instrumentations you want
and then tell it where you want to put
that information
so open telemetry has this idea of the
instrumentation the spans but it also
has this idea of exporters and exporters
of where are you going to send all of
these spans that you create where are
you going to send them to actually
visualize them
and we'll come on to two of those um at
the end obviously i am going to talk
about honeycomb but i'm also going to
talk about the open source solutions in
jager um zipkin still exists um but
jager is predominantly the one that
people use so we'll talk about that one
as well
so
you'll see on this next one
we've just replaced that console
exporter
with the jager exporter
you can have both of them in there you
can have 10 of them in there you have as
many of those exporters as you want and
it will send all of your traces to all
of those exporters
that's what we normally suggest to
people if they are trying out different
providers
to send it to both of us
and see what the difference is because
different providers different exporters
provide different value some people
focus on service mapping some people
focus on high performance and high
cardinality
all of them focus on different things
and it's up to you what's important to
you to know what to do you can add as
many exports as you want just bear in
mind if you're batching things up the
more you back things up the more active
supporters you add the more memory
you're going to use so just bear that
one in mind
so um charles bands
so i talked about what is part of a
trace
um a trace is a an entity it has child
actions that are part of it so if we're
talking about distributed system you've
got your http request that comes in at
the top you've got all the different
micro services that then end up being
part of that if you're writing these
sort of distributed monolith type
methodology you've got lots of http
requests going everywhere if you've got
messaging you've got messages going
everywhere and loads of things
coming back those are all trial traces
now what i want to make clear though is
distributed tracing
doesn't have to be about micro services
you can wrap inside of your code like
this
a particular action so i talked before
about the algorithm
you may have an algorithm in your code
that you want to wrap around and say i'm
going to create a little child spam for
that particular thing
and we'll show something like that
in the demo
so a child span is just creating an
activity from a source so you can see on
this diagram here we're creating an
activity source
which in open telemetry terms would be a
tracer um
and then we're going to create an
activity off the back of that so we're
going to create a span off the back of
there
now i've not done anything with that
span all i've said is that a span has a
time limit
so what i've done is i've wrapped it in
disposable so
that delay is going to come up as 500
milliseconds nothing special on there
we can do a few more bits with that
though
so
that's what charles fan would look like
it doesn't match 500 milliseconds but
that was probably me changing the demo
um so that second delayed process that
you can see there
that's a child spam that's happening
inside the application
and you can see that we've got causality
i talked before about the idea that
tracing is about causality
now you can see from that diagram
that we've got the delayed process is
caused
by that one above it it's not just two
log lines it's actually caused by that
one thing they're part of the same thing
if we had 10 to 15 of these in a
distributed hierarchy then you would be
able to see what one request has caused
throughout all of your systems
our system that we build
has a limit of about 5 000 spans that
you can have on one screen
if you get that large and you need some
help come talk to me because i need to
know what you're doing
so
now we'll talk about attributes
so attributes are these extra things
that you want to know about that spam
about that trace that's coming up
so you can set
arbitrary information on it
you can say i know account type
is what we we might put in there
oh i want to tag all my traces so i've
got the vips
so i can actually monitor the vips
separately to other things that might be
something that's really important to you
it might be your account ids
it might be the number of things inside
of your algorithm that you're analyzing
each time which would allow you to know
well when it's a hundred things that i'm
analyzing the performance is this
whereas when it's 200 things it's this
when it's 500 things it's this these are
all things about when i was talking
about that intentionality about you
thinking about what should i be emitting
from my application
this is you saying this is important to
me
now what you should be doing there is
putting everything that you think might
be relevant
not just the things that you know about
right now that you think are relevant
put everything in there
and this is that idea of when i go into
production i don't know what i didn't
want
it might be the temperature in the data
center is actually really important who
knows if somebody works out how to
actually do that i want to do it in a
demo so if you can like find the
temperature in the data center and stick
it in a span do let me know
okay so what we do there is we're
focusing then on
the information that comes in now
there's two elements the two
terminologies that we use it's called
high cardinality and high dimensionality
so dimensionality is about the number of
attributes or tags that you add to each
one of your spans
you should be adding as many as you as
you can on to there
high cardinality is about providing in
there
information that can have millions of
possible values
so think about account id
now if you've used something like um
prometheus
and you've tried to put a count id on
there to try and map things um i can see
the people smiling at the ones that saw
prometheus rocking in a corner just
going please don't
um
that's about high cardinality metric
systems really struggle with it tracing
systems do not
and that's why you should be putting
those things in there because in high
load systems you do want to know what
proportion of your users are affected is
it one user is it five users it might be
user groups in there you might want to
pop 50 user groups in there and
all those things are
really useful to be put in
okay so now i'm going to talk about um
the foot gun
which is called
um
i wrote a blog post about this because
it really annoys me
um
baggage can get you into a lot of
trouble
now baggage was a w3c standard which is
why it was implemented
and it's the idea of passing context
between two services which sounds simple
you know just
put something on one service and then
when i go into the other service i'd
like to know what that thing was maybe
it's the account id is only available
when i do the claims on the request at
the front
i want to be able to put it on my spans
off the second application sounds
awesome it sounds simple
um
now the problem with that though
is there's this little phrase here
that people forget
and it says you shouldn't put
confidential information in there
and the reason is because it can
transition boundaries outside of your
application
now we talked before about the http
client implementation we've got two
services we've got our service that's
our front end we've got our product
service where we go and get product
information for to render on our service
great on the product service we can say
how many individual users have been
recommend have been getting an
individual product really great
information the problem is our front-end
service also goes off to this currency
exchange service
and gets the exchange rate
and guess what information it puts on
all of those requests because it's http
client
all of your confidential information
goes on all of those requests
because there is no whitelist it doesn't
know what's an internal service what's
an external service
it just puts all of that information on
there
so for that reason
to me it is incredibly dangerous
now it's also just some arbitrary
information it's an arbitrary shrink
um i saw somebody recently
serialize an object into json
base64 encode it and stick it on baggage
anybody heard of viewstate before
that went so well didn't it but that's
what people are doing with these things
because it's just a string and they say
well i want that object in this other
service how just use baggage
that's the bad side of it
that is what makes it very very bad
it is however really really powerful
because it allows you
to in a language agnostic way describe
things that should be on other services
so i talked about account id
an account id is a really important
thing that you might want to use on your
product service to say
this particular high-value product was
coming through and we keep getting
hammered on our product service is it
one user that's causing that
is it some bug in our system it might be
oh it's the vip users are always slow oh
it's only only the normal users it's
fine we don't care about those um
but this idea of being able to transfer
it in a language agnostic way
which means that if your third-party
service or your first party service that
you're using is written in node
god forbid then yes it can
extract that information from baggage
even if it's coming from a net service
or a java service or a go service or a
python service or a php service all of
those have sdks
for open telemetry and baggage provides
a language agnostic way for you to say
here it is account id
you can go and get account id and you
can put it on your spans
one thing to mention is baggage is not
another type of attribute so we talked
before about our attributes that we were
adding to it
and we were putting our
type of awesome thing on there
just by us saying that we're going to
add baggage doesn't mean that that's an
attribute that will go on to your
tracing provider
baggage is a different concept
so how do i add baggage
it's really really really complicated
you call the baggage set baggage
so you want to see that in a little bit
of a wider context um
i'm not expecting everybody to read that
it is
it's actually quite big
so what we're going to be what we're
doing there is we are
setting our baggage
and then we are going to call an
external service and this service that
we're going to call this product info
service is going to get that baggage
information um over which is our account
id that it will be able to extract
and you can see there we've got child
activity within a child activity and you
can go as deep as you want to do
so
that's the that's the baggage stuff i
i like it and i think you should use it
just be really really cautious about
what you do
think about the external services that
you're doing you can clear the request
before you do it so if you're using http
client if it's going to be an external
one
go into your http client clear all the
headers make sure you don't pass the
trace ids
there is an amazing story that if you
come and grab me afterwards i'll tell
you when that went wrong
as a provider that receives traces um
it's a very interesting and funny story
that i won't tell live
but yes that is the
the baggage stuff
um now i'm intentionally not going into
a lot of depth here this is meant to be
a everybody should be using open
telemetry go and use open telemetry
there is no downside to you implementing
open telemetry all of the providers all
of those external providers the
data dog new relic
elastic everyone all the big providers
um that do apm solutions all of them are
moving towards open telemetry as being
their protocol
so you should be doing that what i'm
trying to do here is say how easy it is
to get that basic level of
um
observability
but you should go further you should
start to think about
all the extra bits that you can do all
the manual instrumentation
so
i'm going to do a bit of a demo now
this i talked about before that
personality
this thing here is um our products
honeycomb um which shows you that we've
got something here that's going to call
and get some account information it's
going to call and get some product
information over a second service and
you can see that we're visualizing the
different service names in there
so i'm going to actually show this live
if it works
wish me luck
um
so
there we go so what i've got here is
just two basic services in net they're
using minimal apis um so we've got on
the left is our service one with a few
different routes on it doing some
different things
um is that can the people at the back
can you read that all right do you want
me to zoom in
zoom zoom okay
and
so we'll open it one by one then
all right how's that
good okay so
service one we're doing what we said
before we're going to add our extra
source so we talked about activity
source we create an activity source that
allows us to separate some of our
methods
now what we need to do is tell open
telemetry to listen to that source
because it's emitted as part of activity
an activity source we need to tell open
telemetry when it runs go and listen to
that thing
what we're also going to do as i said
before we're going to have two exporters
we're going to add our jager exporter
and we're going to add our
honeycomb exporter i wonder if i've got
the console exporter
um if that works as well
i don't have it but you could add more
exporters in there if you wanted to so
this is our front end service
we've got basic route this is on github
by the way so you can take this away and
use it um
entirely up to you
at your own risk if it burns down your
data center it was not me
um
so our first thing with our first one
here is our child spam we're going to
add our account id as baggage onto there
the more complicated one is this one and
this is our
showing of baggage and i'm going to show
this one as a
as an example of how we can do it
because
it's the more advanced one
so what we're going to do here we're
going to go and get our http client
which is going to set our base address
to our other service
we're going to create a dummy account id
because i'm going to write an account
service as well um
and we're going to create a child
activity now the this one here between
lines 52 and 58
that would be where i would see
something like an internal algorithm
that you wanted to do you just want to
wrap that thing you want to add some
information to it we've gone and got
some account information that kind of
stuff
the second one is our product and what
we've got inside of here now is two
different child activities
they're not causality of each other
so our baggage
causes an account activity
but our account activity doesn't cause a
product activity
that's up to you to decide what's
important to you in an application and
this is where i talk about this
intentionality because you know what's
important and you know what you want to
see our product activity is going to set
a tag on our product activity span
and it's going to call out to a product
info service
which is then going to return us some
information about a product
okay
our second service
is even simpler
so our second service we're going to do
the same thing we're going to set up our
jager exporter and our honeycomb
exporter
you'll notice on here it doesn't have an
activity source and that's because we're
not creating any internal spans in this
one
all we're going to use is the standard
asp net spans
and you can see here what we're doing is
we're using the current activity which
is a thread safe way to get the current
activity that is active
inside of your application and we're
just going to tack some more attributes
onto it because we don't care about
creating another subspan
and then we're just going to return that
information
like i say incredibly simple
so
i'm going to run that
if i get into the right directory
and you know this isn't going to work
now because you know
i didn't do the ritual sacrifices before
i came on the tour
um okay so
um we've got our baggage endpoint this
is our service one um that we're doing
we're just gonna hit that you see it's
taking a little bit of time the reason
is because i put some delays in so it
makes our span look good
um so we're gonna do a couple of
those now
i'm going to show jaeger first
so jager what i've done here i've run
this up locally
in a
in a container it's
one line it's not hard um you should be
able to do this if you've got docker
desktop
i would advise that you start doing this
locally just so that you can start to
see it and there are some initiatives
around how do we visualize traces
without external applications um so
particularly putting things like
graphical analyzers on the console but
at the moment the only way to visualize
your traces especially in net is to have
something like jager um or some other
third-party product like us um which we
do have a free tip by the way that you
can all use um
so that's that's my wages covered now um
so
you need something else to visualize
them so you can see here this is our
trace of our front-end service um let's
zoom in a little bit here
so you can see we've got that
causality so what we've got there is our
first top level services are called to
account
we've then got our second bit which is
our running of getting that account
information which is just our dummy um
500 millisecond
rule
and then we've got our um get onto that
other service so you can see front end
service and product service are the two
different things and if we zoom out a
little bit you can start to see our
traces
um our waterfall chart and these are the
things that you would know if you if
you've been doing tracing if you've been
doing things like continuous profiling
with um apm tools you'll be used to this
kind of stuff
but this is about you being intentional
about what you do rather than this being
all automatic and it's also vendor
agnostic
so that you can switch provider whatever
you want and it's something that we
advocate for because if we're not the
best move on so
um but we can see there we've got our
different 500 milliseconds is around
that so what we're adding about nine
milliseconds on to the asp.net
is what's adding on to our calls
then we can start to drill in
and start to see some of the tags that
have been added so those ones there
those are the default ones i was talking
about so when we do asp.net core into
instrumentation we say just give us
everything that's the information it's
going to give us
now these are standard attributes
so http host http method these are
standardized in the open telemetry specs
there is a semantic naming that they
talk about so if you're using azure
there's a load of azure attributes that
start with azure dot there's aws for aws
store apparently there's some googly
thing um that has its own
um but you've also got things like the
open telemetry library so what library
version am i doing and these are all
really interesting things that you might
want to know what's the assembly version
of my libraries
because it could be that you've got some
old code running in your application
you've done a kubernetes deployment it's
not a rolling deployment you've got one
stuck pod
living there so you might want to put
all those things out there
and then we've got all our honeycomb
attributes as well um
and now we start to get to the stuff
that we've added ourselves
so you can see there we've got that
account type thing that i added in there
now when we're going to get down to this
bottom one here
which is the span for our product
service
you can also see that we've got account
id
now the product service request didn't
get account id all it got was the
account number that the product id
it didn't get an account number but what
we did is we passed that over in baggage
because you know we like to live life
dangerously so we've put that in there
and what we've done with that
if we go back to the code
if you look at this line here
we go and get the baggage
so we get a known parameter of account
id
out of baggage
and then we set that as an attribute
that's the thing that catches
almost every person i speak to out they
say i've added my baggage
but all of my child's fans don't have
that attribute
and that's because that isn't what
baggage is
baggage is an ability to send the
context between services
it's not the ability to add it to spans
there are
solutions out there that will take all
of those active all of those baggage
things and apply them as spam attributes
i don't advise using them some people do
i do not um it is dangerous because
those things that come in those baggage
things could come in from external
services
so if you've got a publicly available
service
what if somebody sends over to you
a load of baggage attributes are just
going to take all those and apply them
to all of your spams
is that useful probably not
ingo is the only language right now that
has the ability to say i am a public
endpoint ignore all of the baggage
we will get one in dot-net soon
but it isn't there at the
moment so that's our
jaeger exporter and you can see
we've got product id that one's coming
through as an integer we've got account
id it's coming through as a guide i mean
this is all basic stuff
but now we can start doing some
interesting stuff with that data
because we've got this stuff in
our jaeger stuff we can start to do some
searching on well let's just find all of
the account info ones
anything that contains an account info
attribute now my issue with jaeger is
it's hard to scale it uses cassandra
under the hood um if you want to try and
run this internally then you're going to
have to start thinking about how you
scale cassandra
when you start to think about thousands
and thousands and millions of traces
it is very very good for doing this
basic level of stuff and if you've got
some small value services some small
services that you run absolutely jaeger
will be providing you much better than
just a logging solution
just taking something throwing it
through fluentd fluent bit and then
displaying some log attributes you're
going to get a lot more information by
doing this because you're going to get
that causality
now if we look at those same things on
our service
if you want to go that's fine this is
the what we do
it is much better
but i am ever so slightly biased
so
what we've got here is a the same sort
of trace that we've got on there
which
you know it's exactly the same thing um
that you've got
other than the fact that we've now got
some more information
down the side
um and this is where we say that
open telemetry
isn't special it doesn't it's not
special your exporters they get the same
information it's all about what you do
with them
now for us we focus on the high
cardinality attributes
so things like user ids high performance
and that's our focus
so that you can start to see things like
the um
the heat maps
of your requests
which is not going to be very big on
this one but we can start to do things
like
a
a heat map on your duration to see where
of where are all the requests going that
are quite i mean there's only two
requests there so you can
can't really see much in there but you
can start to see a lot more information
um
through these exporters
but you can send it to all of the
exporters you can send it to one
exporter you can start to trade off
different
exporters to see which one is the the
one that's going to provide you with the
best information
okay
so i've looked at honeycomb and we've
looked at jaeger as outputs as exporters
um as that terminology
now the other thing that you can do is
especially if you're using
high volume systems if you've got 50 70
god forbid fifteen hundred micro
services in your application
managing the keys to send to different
places is going to be quite hard
you've got fifty if you have a key that
expires you've got fifteen hundred
deployments to go and send that change
all that information to change your
external stuff
now open telemetry has something called
a collector
a collector is an exporter
the same as jaeger the same as
we are
but it's more of an aggregator so it
will take all of your spam data in and
allow you to do something central with
it now that might just be send it all
here and we'll send it out
that's really useful if you've got a
constrained environment a secure
environment where what you need to do is
send um all of your data out through one
egress endpoint
so you've got a my services can't talk
to external services
so what i need to do is i need to send
them to something else that something
else can talk to one endpoint and that
might be your provider that you're
sending now it might be to your jaeger
instance that's really useful in hyper
secure environments
it's also useful if you've got a third
party that has
keys
because you can change your keys in one
or multiple locations in your collector
and only in your collector
there's also some really interesting
things inside the collector because it
can do post processing
on your spans
now if you're in an environment which um
you might be outputting
personal information you might be
handling some personal information
it can be really useful from in one
specific location to say anytime you see
something that's a 16-digit number
probably want to remove that because
that's something before i send it on to
my third party provider
i don't want them to get the credit
cards
so you can provide these redaction
filters there's a redaction processor
that you can put in that says search for
something that looks like this it might
be a an attribute called first name
remove that we don't want it i still
want you to send all this other
information up but remove these bits of
information from a security context it's
quite useful to be able to do that sort
of stuff
you can also do
in some of the languages and i said
before in dot net it's not a particular
problem in dot net
where we put things into a background
process and then in that background
process we will then send that
information over to a third party
asynchronously so it doesn't actually
affect your request
there are languages that don't do that
there are languages where it will send
out that information
synchronously
so if your third party provider has a
blip and it takes them 10 seconds to
receive that information your http
request now takes whatever you were
doing plus 10 seconds
which is not great the collector allows
you to say in my application i'm just
going to send my information straight to
this collector and the collector will
handle all those retries all of that
offline stuff
now one place that's particularly
useful is in azure functions
because azure functions doesn't have a
background process
for you to be able to send that
information into and that background
process to be able to run
it's a lot better in our process
functions but it is still a problem so
using something like the collector you
can co-host that in a location close to
your functions and be able to
synchronously send all of your spans to
that collector and have that push that
information out to wherever it needs to
go whether it's jaeger or third-party
providers
now it also provides this really
interesting capability for centralized
enrichment
so
in a kubernetes environment
you might want to say
i'd like to tag everything with the
namespace
all these spans that come over i want to
tag it with the namespace i want to tag
it with a pod id i want to tag it with
the region that these things are in
now what this allows you to do because
you're sending it through the collector
now
you don't have to worry about that in
your application so in your application
you don't have to worry about the tags
that you're going to add you don't have
to worry about am i hosted in kubernetes
am i hosted in container apps and i
hosted in something else
using a collector it can say oh you came
from a container app you can t you came
from a pod in kubernetes i'm going to
work out what the details of that pod
are and i'm going to do that in richmond
which again is a very very
interesting use case for the collector
once you get to a significant size i
would always recommend you use the
collector instead of going direct
so if you're using something that's
incredibly high volume
go through the collector if you're using
something that's got more than say two
or three micro services that all need
that same key to go to that same
external service put a collector in
it's very very lightweight it can run as
a container it can run as an application
you can run it as sidecars
inside of
the
inside of kubernetes
now the one thing i haven't got a slide
on at the moment because it's only in
beta at the moment
is something called the open
opentelemetryagentfor.net
now
i don't agree with the concept i will be
open with that um because it's about
auto instrumentation rather than being
intentional but this allows you in the
worlds if you've been doing tracing and
doing apm tools in the past where you
would install an agent on your vm
put it next to your.net application and
say instrumentthis.net application and
give me all of the information
there is now an
opentelemetryagentfor.net
that you can run as a sidecar container
in kubernetes and point that to your
application and get a all of that auto
instrumentation that we were talking
about it will go in and find all that
information it's only in beta at the
moment it might even be an alpha it is
very very new
but it does allow you to say if you're
somebody who doesn't have the ability to
change the code
then you can apply this collector this
agent
and get that agent to then send those to
the collector and then the collector can
then forward those up and you get a nice
open source
vendor agnostic solution for taking
tracing and span data and sending that
elsewhere
so
that's me
i am happy to take some questions
um i managed to get at least four well
uh what 45 minutes out of about 10 lines
of code which i think is pretty
impressive um but i'm more than happy to
take any questions or if you want to
come and see me um come and have a chat
we do honeycomb do observability office
hours um so if you go onto our website
if you've got some specific questions
some problems that kind of stuff by all
means come to us it doesn't have to be
about what we're doing um we are
what we consider to be the observability
experts because we've been doing this
for the longest in terms of
observability
but by all means book some time with us
and we can happily go through some
specific use cases with you
oh two questions
do you want to shout um and i'll repeat
i'll go with you
and first really nice
okay so the question was in open
telemetry we have traces traces are a
first-class citizen um we've also
metrics has just gone live so metrics is
part of the open telemetry spec at the
moment it's not ga inside of the net
sdks at the moment but there is also an
initiative called open telemetry logs
which is the idea of standardizing the
protocol of how logs get sent to vendors
dot net crowd so pretty much everybody's
heard of serilog and serialog has
multiple different syncs
that allow you to send it to various
different locations each one of those
things is specific to a vendor
open telemetry logs is the idea of how
do we standardize logs we've
standardized how we send traces we've
standardized how we set metrics and now
we're going to standardize how we do
logs
logs in.net is not fully fledged at the
moment i would not recommend using it
yet we're only a few months away though
so keep checking the um keep checking
the sites
the protocol so the idea of what the
schema is when it gets sent to a vendor
that stuff has all been finalized it was
finalized last month i think it was just
as kubecon happened where we did the
project meetings um so the protocol has
and now all of the sdks need to
implement it and then the vendors need
to implement the protocol as well
we're not far off i wouldn't recommend
logs just yet but it's not far off
cool
so building a service map so the idea is
the answer the question is within
honeycomb specifically do we have the
ability to do a service map um yes it is
coming it's not there yet
very very close i would love to show it
but the engineering team would kill me
and i do like my job
oh sorry
so the big difference and this is
something that so the the question was
um how do spans and traces relate to
logging because they seem to
solve a similar space of problem
the big difference between spans which
would be the equivalent of structured
logs is causality
so the idea of a span
is that it is descendant from something
else
so in a span the core three attributes
you have are the trace id
the current span id so the unique id of
this span
but also the parent id of that span
so which one caused me to happen
and that's the big difference with
tracing
is the ability to say this particular
entry was caused by this one but it's
part of this larger thing
we've had in logging the ability to put
correlation ids in for instance for a
while the causation stuff is the stuff
that
isn't really in the logging space at the
moment obviously you can do this in
structured logs
the idea of a spam
is just a json blob with attributes on
it
you could absolutely have created this
in the past
we're just saying my structured log has
this parent span id this um parent and
this trace id you could absolutely have
done that
but that idea of saying that this is how
a spam works this standardization of a
span it has to have this bit these bits
of information it has to have a context
it has to have a duration
all of these things are making that
a subset of structured logs if you want
because it's about saying that all of
these providers all of these exporters
take this in in a particular way
one thousand percent get rid of logs
they can get in the bin
[Laughter]
so yes i believe that we should be
killing logs i don't believe logs in the
context of where we're moving with
microservices where we're looking at
high volume systems where
the only place that you will see the the
actual usage of your application is in
production logs do not give you that
logs can give you a lot of stuff when
you run locally because you've got one
request going through it's you doing
your request and you can see those logs
when you're in a production system
logs just don't give you that i'm
looking at a log between 17 different
services to work out where the problem
is and i'm trying to grab all of those
logs and send them to one place
that not only takes time because i've
got to send all of these traces to one
location i've got to throw them through
an elk stack to then aggregate this
information up i've got to throw them
through any kind of number of processing
pipelines takes time to get those things
up the idea of traces is that already
exists
so to me
yes you shouldn't be using logs really
anymore
but
they do provide some benefit we call
them observability light
because they will give you some of the
observability
they will allow you to do some some
things
but they're not as good as tracing is
tracing is going to give you that
causality it's going to give you the
ability to look at a production system
and see that information coming out of
it
does that answer your question
awesome
any more questions
mark hello
you can make it do that
i generally would not recommend it for
that kind of stuff when you're putting a
stack trace in there so the question was
if i throw an exception in my code and
it's an unhandled exception um can i
have that inside of my stack trace
inside of my spam you can there is an
attribute on the asp.net core
instrumentation for record exception
which will record all of that exception
data in there it becomes less useful
when you're trying to do things like
heuristics on that um that logging
information
the exceptions there are better tools
out there than a lot of the
observability vendors for doing tracing
because when you get an exception what
you want to be able to do is have a look
at that stack trace and find some
commonalities with other stack traces
that might have happened
that stuff is
beyond the capabilities of tracing at
the moment also there are some providers
that do it but it is a an extra bit on
top of that so yes you can
um
how useful that is it's entirely up to
you but this is all what i say about the
intentionality of what you're doing
if you're going to put it on there you
need to be actually using it
you need to be thinking about this will
be useful at some point
or it might be useful
any more
what about in telemetry for example
tracing that how uh how mature is
so the question was around user
telemetry um so the terminology for that
is real user monitoring or rom um there
is a project ongoing in open telemetry
to
bring in a run project which is
apparently starting next month um so
they've got a special interest group
that's forming to think about how do we
standardize on rom now we've done
tracing we've done metrics
we've done logs
now what do we do around real user
monitoring
um so how do we look at the um the
tracing of front end application to work
out user sessions because
is a session a trace when a session
could be four hours long that's not
really the same sort of thing so there's
a whole committee that's forming around
that same thing it's all about telemetry
how do we get to that point where we've
got a standardized approach to real user
monitoring now so that the vendors can
be then standardizing around that thing
so at the moment there isn't really a
story for it
any more
questions
awesome right well thank you very much
for coming and um i hope you all got at
least something out of this but main
takeaway for me go and use open
telemetry and then whichever vendor you
use use it through open telemetry
[Applause]
you